はいみなさんよすべきです
チョップはいろいろ笠間って体重1週間で5キロ減っドア
肇社長です元気だったかい三連休どうだった
僕はね三連休全部出て完全復活しましたよ
まあ風だけじゃなくて
まだバイトとか
マイターそうライトとカート大学の行ずねー
実習的なやつがあって
プエルトが入ってすごい日焼けとかしたり
あげれない日々が続いておかげさまで
ん
もうすぐ体重がいい
60キロを切るぐらいすごいスリムにする部になったと思うんですけど
またぼちぼちないん
意味わかんない動画とか出していこうと思いますよ
ああ僕がー
床で寝ている間に
いろんなことがあったと僕が聞いたんなぜだ
どっか撮ろうゾーンのクソ野郎がぁ
アイスとの中に入ったとかバカヤロする俺はしそういうことしてないでありなぜか着い
た買っていったなぁ
あれですねクーラーあたり水墨1回クーラーねー
記述したことがあるあれは高3の夏時だったん
俺は行きたい大学があって必死に必死に勉強していた
なんだっけな育英だっけ郁恵
塾みたいななんか頭のいい人が集まる宿みたいなところに入って書き号数とかを受けて
すごい頑張ったけど
まぁ案の定皆さんわかると思うんですけどずっと勝ってクーラーが強いですよ
沿って南下クーラーの風が当たりすぎて
目の前が真っ白になって
ブッチャーれちゃいましたね
そういうこともあるんでクーラー当たりすぎは気をつけてくださいね
ちょっと本当に痩せすぎてほんとやばいいんだよ
またねなんか食べたり飲んだりする動画が合ってると思うんですけど
何気楽に見てもらえればありがたいですいうわけで気
完全復活したんでね
ちょっと忙しいんで毎日はきついかもしれないんですけど
またねー
このスマートになったはず3冊を
まあまあ期待しないでください
ん